i love you in that top you know
i was just thinking right now first of
all thank you but i think i wore
the wrong color to do a strawberry mask
right now
i think i might have too well
what were they thinking um but it's okay
it washes out
we're also here to present what we do
privately at home
so exactly um all right so we just made
this really healthy breakfast that was
totally groundbreaking and original
and now teach us how to use the
remaining strawberries to
beautify ourselves so this is a great
thing to do with maybe some strawberries
that
are too ripe or super bruised and you
really don't want to eat them but you
don't want to waste them either
and what i love about strawberries is
that when you use it on the skin
there's it's actually a natural acid
like a fruit acid in the strawberries
so it helps eat away at all the dead
skin cells on your face
wow the other thing that's possible the
vitamin c
see very good drew
[Laughter]
so we also have yogurt and so what we're
going to start with
is like a big spoonful of yogurt yogurt
has lactic acid in it which is also
great for your skin
and we're just going to add this to a
bowl and then we're going to add
something called betanite clay bed
nightclay is a volcanic ash that's been
around for
and used for thousands of years you find
it at
the health food store this is something
that's really good at like if you think
about clay it purges things out of the
pores
and it's funny that you mentioned like
where do you get it because that's
exactly when i heard volcanic ash i was
like where does
one procure volcanic ash
from your volcanic ash dealer supply
now we need a little bit of honey honey
is an intense
moisturizer um it's something that's
also very antibacterial on your skin so
it's great for acne prone skin so we're
just gonna do a big thing of honey
right into the bowl i just think honey
is like straight up sexy it's like it
really
is a beautiful flavor i love the texture
i love the color
it's so natural it enhances everything
that's the price of admission to be a
guest on your show right now thank you
my pleasure it is that is awesome and
then we're just going to do two more
things we have the oats
just a sprinkling of oats this is going
to be really helping with
inflammation and for irritated skin the
oats
and then we take one or two strawberries
this is the fun part drew and then we
just smash them
just pulverize them in your hands
i love an interactive dish oh my
goodness
that's perfect it just feels good too
like i already hold on so
tight in life it's nice to know it's
useful somewhere
and then um when it's all mixed together
what you do you want to use it fresh so
this is enough to make one
healthy face mask and we and we just put
it on our skin
i'll show you how to do it you just put
it on
your face like this and the key thing is
you want to leave it on for about 15
to 20 minutes so that all the acids can
eat away
at the dead skin cells everything can
really do its magic but you don't want
to leave it on for too long because it
also can
over strip and over dry out the skin too
what do you think it smells amazing
doesn't it gosh
it ha you know what's so interesting is
it really smells acidic
like you can you can smell the inner
workings
it doesn't feel frivolous and that
yogurt factor is um really key
like for um you know
a lot of like teas and yogurts
have been recommended for that sort of
you know
wellness trick um and i find yogurt
extremely healing
you can put tea bags on things yogurts
they're
you know more anti-inflammatory
ah i feel good and i'm gonna look
good which is always exciting listen
i'll put anything
on my face that's natural to keep me you
know
looking and feeling good i i'm
i am like a junkie about it that's why i
call myself a beauty junkie because i
just think there are little hacks
and tricks and tools that we can use to
make ourselves look better and then it
affects the way we feel and how we
present ourselves
and i can feel it working it is
sometimes you put stuff on you're like
what is this doing i can feel this like
pulling yeah yeah you don't want you
don't want this to over strip the skin
but i will say
anyone who's going to try this at home
leave it on for 15 to 20 minutes and
then thoroughly rinse it off with
warm water and follow with your favorite
moisturizer and toner
and always do a little pat pat pat don't
over
because i can over scrub and work this
is you want to remove them very very
gently
um well those are all the best tips this
feels amazing i don't want to take it
off but i will
go to the drewberrymore show.com for the
breakfast pokeball recipe
and instructions on the strawberry oat
mask
danny theo
[Music]
you